okay well for those who are joining this
livestream we are going to be talking
about some of our new blockchain
functionality that's coming in version
12 and my goal is to understand some of
the workflows that we are going to be
supporting and try and make sure they
all make sense all right so let's start
off with a standard Bitcoin transaction
here so the basic idea is that so wait a
minute where did that transaction ID
come from so if you want a more complete
version of these maybe you can open the
workflow which workflow so this is which
one is that transfer Bitcoin between
addresses annoys that guys um okay okay
so crea
Bitcoin private key to be used for
sending Bitcoin okay so this is this is
going to be my it's going to effectively
define my account that correct it's
their first step to you had to create
your beacon address okay all right so
okay so this is a key pair but I'm only
getting the public the private part of
that keeper what am i doing with the
public part of that key pair you're
gonna use that in launching key in
called Bart beginner generate your
address there's a baseline if I'm
understanding this line correctly this
line is storing only the private key or
is the precedence of that such that so
if I do this and then I say um yeah
that's only the private key so the
public just got lost here well their
blood chinking code function knows that
he has to use a public key so you can
provide blah blah blah well I don't
understand I don't know son I'm very
confused here this Center key this line
here stores only the private key when I
do to generate a symmetric key pair
right that's gonna generate both private
and public keys right but this line
saves only the private key yes okay so
what happens here
so here when you provide that private
key actually if you open the you expand
the blog of the sender key in your
notebook at the left oh no wait a minute
good wait a minute wait a minute it
doesn't give the public key in here no
but it has information to to generate
the public key so so the blockchain key
function already knows that and without
information it will derive the address
from your public key
um so it's it's saving you one step okay
so um okay so this is okay so this thing
here let me just try to understand what
this is doing so this is encoding an
address for that block does it need to
know what the blockchain is why does it
need to know the blockchain because the
first character is different
so how you encode it you use different
characters if it's a minute or it or if
it's destined it okay fair enough
and in this case just some basic example
we are sending it going from one address
owned by us to another address also
owned by us
yes it's example ok ok but so for
example ok fair enough
so like if I was going to use ok fine
so then
the receiver all right okay I get it
so that's the Bitcoin address from that
private key all right so now we go to a
Bitcoin tested faucet that will give us
free take bitcoins and we enter there
the sender key because we need to have
some bit conciliated to that sender
address so that's how we get the
bitcoins through that faucet okay okay
okay
and that transaction ID the one you were
asking before is basically this one the
one that intersection ID that the faucet
gave us which is the transaction ID
where our transaction okay so there's
the transaction and this is the
transaction okay
and now you're asking for the outputs of
that transit so that's the transaction
that the faucet did now you're asking
for the outputs from that transaction
and it says boy that's a lot of Bitcoin
um yeah that because those are the
bitcoins owned by the faucet and the
second one the last output is there wait
a minute wait a minute so this
I don't understand this what what well
by the way I've got an echo on this some
phone but but I don't understand what
this output means so there are two
outputs here these remember that
transaction was created by the faucet
right mm-hmm so the fuzz had created two
outputs one output is the last one the
0.18 bitcoins that you see the address
there is the it's our that were city
address we created we put a private key
and the first output is what they are
sending back to them those are not our
bitcoins but wait a minute that's saying
that they took all the bitcoins that
were at their address which is this
thing here is that right that's the
receiver
that's not us that's that no that's
that's one of their addresses so we
never went that wengie transfer bitcoins
you you need to transfer your whole
output some way yeah I understand so
it's transferring it back to itself most
of it back to its develop and some of it
to us yes that's great okay so
then why is there a dress longer than
our dress or is it an illusion
I'm not sure and you check
I may just be an odd fixed-width font
it's a bit odd
that's a bit odd if I might say so
oh I believe because their address is a
page of public key hush I mean I paid to
public script hush address and and our
address here is a page of public key
cache address so there are a little bit
different I didn't understand that
explain that again so in our case our
our address is representing a baby
public key cash transaction which is a
very standard transaction that is
related to to the to a hash of a public
key in their case their address is
representing the transaction that is
related to the hash of a script so to
use our bitcoins we need to provide
private key for them to use your
bitcoins they need to provide a script
so it's a little bit different I see and
we don't annotate that fact that those
are different what a mess my god okay
now this let's look at the script string
okay um what is the status of our
virtual machine for these
we have our prototype can you show me
us that string and turn it into some
symbolic representation not completely
because the he needs to connect see
there are some up goes here they needed
information from the blockchain but can
I see what it can actually do and then
and then can you explain to me what that
hash is there what is that so that one
is the hash of a public key which is I
see that's our
I thought this was a public key that's
address and what we are doing here so
this a script stream here is the
unlocking mechanism that this
transaction is providing so when we want
to use those bitcoins we have to provide
a first part of a string that has a
public key and a signature the signature
comes from our private key so when you
combine both scripts they they run and
you get a true result if the result is
true
that means we can use those bitcoins so
this is the last part of the script and
we have to provide the first part of the
script to unlock this output and use the
bitcoins and that will happen in the
next section
okay I'm a little confused by this but
okay fair enough okay
a cup amount
okay
okay so Wilma what happened here so
Willman
this is I see this is they had put this
is in our sender
faucitt had transferred bitcoin to our
sander correct to our sanders address
right it created an output that is
linked to our Center address and that
means that we have the private key to
use this output here I understand but it
effectively transferred this amount of
Bitcoin to our to that address that we
specified yes I wouldn't say that that
it's exactly correct because you're you
don't transfer bitcoins to an address to
create new outputs and you associate out
output an address and we can say yeah I
mean it's it's easier to say that you
transfer some amount you an address but
in reality what it's happening is that
you are creating is grading it's like
creating a safe with a lock that has
that only your key can open basically
yeah okay
by the way do we have nice
visualizations of things like the you
know taking sort of a ribbon of the
total Bitcoin and the for set how we're
slicing that off one piece goes to us
one piece goes back to the faucet do we
have any nice visualization of that we
we made sama thin but we can prepare I
think that will be useful for some of
our educational outreach I miss Carla
and our live stream is saying is there a
background in context section and the
docs for each of these functions to
enlighten on Bitcoin aficionados how
they work a good question and a not a
bad suggestion either I mean this is I
don't know what let's take a look at
Bitcoin transaction data
that is actually a pretty good
suggestion um and maybe we should try to
write that I mean in the end this is
complicated stuff and hopefully we will
have some courses about it but you're
aware of you know some of our pages
right are starting to have but there's
one here a background and context
section
all right I see I think it would be a
good idea to try and write some of those
for these Bitcoin functions to give some
idea of what the function you know what
the point of the function is uhm I think
I'd be great to do that but it will not
be sufficient because it's a pretty
complicated area um but it's it will at
least give people more of a fighting
chance of understanding what's going on
okay so now what are we going to do
we're going to take the stuff that was
at this
Sandra address and get ready to transfer
it to the risk my gosh this is
complicated Wow
oh my gosh what a mess right so now we
went to transfer that money we got from
the faucet to our other address the one
you also generated at the double
um so in reality that will usually
belong to another person in this case is
yes for you to test how G transfer
bitcoins between two addresses on bite
you okay okay well so check your balance
by inspecting the output of the
transaction okay
that's what we just did that's that was
the thing we just looked at okay
okay so now convert bla ba ba ba okay
build the transaction object okay so we
want to send point zero five bitcoins
we are offering that fee yes wouldn't it
be better to give that fee enter Tosh's
here yeah yeah we can also do
just say what does it do if I just say
currency convert of a thing oh it
requests a second argument I wonder
whether it should just do based on
geolocation um
a suggestion for the currency conversion
folk I mean I think if I say geolocation
country I will get a definite thing and
arguably I should get a definite thing
and arguably we should do currency
convert with one argument should go to
the local currency could could who's
coming here me Carla I can turn that
over
could you send that I guess darlin okay
um okay all right so how do we set I
think you should explain in this
workflow where that fee comes from how
you determine that fee so in in this
case wheel we have work a lot with test
knit and we know that this amount of fee
is basically the Liffey that were for us
to get a block alade dating in the next
like five minutes or ten minutes so
that's something we're ready you should
say that gotta say that here because
otherwise somebody who's reading this
workflow says how do I know what the
speed should be wouldn't it be
interesting if we had some function that
could tell one the prevalent fee
in other words it could just look at
some recent transactions and look at
their fees
yeah we can also do it let me check on
um I think that would be a nice thing to
have
I mean perhaps it's a function
repository function or something yeah so
we actually talk about caffeine so
constantly run some stats of the other
of our different blood chain switchboard
to to get for example like the minimum
fee and the maximum fee a little of the
last let's say 10 blocks so that gets
your idea of good throat how are we
doing that how would we do that we we
can check the we just get their last ten
blocks and add a transaction okay so if
I look at blockchain um
if I look at blockchain data right for
this blockchain right
okay oh I see oh there we go yeah but I
think we can get more more stats not
just that we can get more row but that's
already useful but when you show it here
you should show how you derive that fee
okay and you should say for example it
might be one twenty percent above the
minimum fee or something you should say
what you do so like here if I just say
get me the minimum fee here um okay and
now I have no idea what that is can't
say convert okay
I see so so then what I would do here
can I edit this right no I can't your
copy I didn't I didn't check it out but
what I'm suggesting is that you put in
there you know show this show the fact
that as a minimum fee say it's 1.2 times
um the UM the minimum fee right right or
whatever it is okay okay all right so
let's keep going here
all right change what does this mean
this means so since we are sending some
money to our receiver address we also
have to send money back to us while
we're first okay all right so let's
build the transaction okay
so
so that transition transaction ID is
where you can find the output that the
faucet generated for us there will be
the some cells above I think where I put
check your balance or something like
that
so that's in transaction ID and the
index is the output index in the case of
beeping you start counting from zero
wait I'm sorry I'm sorry I met with
something has this transaction I did
where did this come from
safety scroll up okay and you see that
blockchain transaction data so yeah okay
so you copy pasted it from here can I
suggest that in terms of the flow of
this document that you say you know for
set ID equals or something or for set
equals this thing and then you use that
for these places so there's just a
mystery thing that goes in here um okay
so the input is that transaction what is
the index equals one thing they indexed
so if you scroll up you see that we have
remember we have two outputs one for
them and one for for us the second one
that's in x1 because it's our
transaction right okay and the outputs
and the transaction we're trying to
build are an amount
that address and amounts at that address
okay I get it okay sign the transaction
with the sender's private key okay
okay
submit the transaction to the blockchain
find the transaction there's a I bother
that shows a bit but the contest not
okay so that's the ID
I think you should show those in
separate lines okay don't don't put
these together in one line okay however
have it see the transaction ID
and you can say just say slash slash
dataset here
right transaction data equals that / /
dataset okay
well hopefully you will already have
computed this check the new transaction
output
by the amount sent to the receivers
address
that's just to verify that yeah okay I
get it
so ideally our same crazy if I might say
so that way I mean showing that just
seems I mean presumably the right way to
do this when we have system credential
is to save it in the system keychain is
that right would you do it somewhere
that will be that will be idea yes and
eventually we want to build logic wallet
on top of that for now it's just a
simple example how to save your I
wouldn't I wouldn't say D : I mean
that's a that's a you know that just
happens to be the boss whatever just
just say private key stuff W I'll just
save it to the current directory makes
sense okay
so that's the most simple case I put my
weight aside website but the way you're
saving those private keys
don't you want to save
well I mean this is an unrealistic
example because you would save those
keys to different places I mean if this
was using system credential okay um
wouldn't I don't understand what what it
would look like do we have anybody here
who knows how system credential is
supposed to work I mean this will be
system credential of whatever your name
is for that thing equals and then the
private key right
mmm-hmm call on a live stream is asking
whether there's something like a pen
file that is standardly used for these I
don't know what is the standard is there
a standard wallet format
I think I think that differs depending
on the blockchain
but for bent files
I believe let me check I remember let's
find this out because it may be not an
import/export format that we should have
which is a wallet format for different
block chains
okay so let me see if I understand if
I'm gonna go to the local Bitcoin ATM
okay I simply want to get paid you know
I want to convert my dollars to Bitcoin
all I have to do here if I'm not
mistaken is let me see if I understand
the flow what I would do is I would take
this
I would generate one of those I would
make sure I am appropriately save that
private key right yes then I would go
and I would do this blockchain so here's
what I would do I would say um
I really actually what I would call this
is I would say it's my key equals this
okay so this is using a Bitcoin ATM and
I'm going to save this someplace um
you
actually I there's there's a notebook I
send you about using a big Canadian okay
well let me see if I can figure it out
for myself Chester
so um okay
[Music]
okay
so I generate my key then I say block
Tankian code to Bitcoin not the test net
but the main end right
okay and there I have this magnificent
thing then let's say that this something
like my address yeah okay actually I
want to say my key here
okay so now I would say barcode image of
my address call my QR code right right
and you can do like it's a message using
MMS you said that your cell phone
because that's what happens if I try
doing that
you
what do I do I say MMS so you can't he
writes a message the channel is MMS and
the next argument is isn't the default
to all that let me just see what happens
here
why is this confused
what is it doing okay who knows about
this
that what is going on there
I am very confused but now it's it's
made the colonel go away so let's take a
look at some message
you
and an S message so this will send it
why isn't this working
let's see if I can send an SMS
like let's just check that I'm
cloud-connected
I think I have to be cloud-connected for
any of this yes
okay that's okay um send message hello
there we have to testify the channel
first
Hamas I think that the Colonel crash
when it was trying to out update the
buglet alright hold you got something
hopefully um okay so why did it not work
here
can you rerun the to get the key and the
address again please yeah
[Music]
you
okay let's try doing this
[Music]
see
so sending it to some random non-real
phone and see what and I can check that
down
now beautiful
magnificent the arsenic yard code in
your cell phone yeah yeah I have the QR
code right here I haven't used a Bitcoin
ATM but do they have a QR code scanner
or how do you think my dear they do they
have a they have a here I'll show you
what this so what what should happen is
I should be able to
ah see we go
magnificent right so I should be able to
just hold that up to the Bitcoin ATM and
it shouldn't it should be able to okay
so this is very straightforward okay so
now I've done that now what will I see
so then the Bitcoin ATM will give me a
receipt which is a transaction ID right
yes yes and then I should be able to go
to the blockchain and see that
transaction going through now the other
way round what I want to do yeah let's
say I want to the other part of this is
can I get the the ATM to disgorge money
to me right and for that I presumably
need to give it what do I need to give
it to to have it so this is giving it
money what happens if I want it to
well so this would be what I would do if
I want to pay somebody else this
rigmarole is what I have to go through
to take what I you know what I put on
the blockchain here I could then pay to
somebody else but what if I want the ATM
to give me back dollars
what do I do I would presumably give it
a signed transaction like this right
whether ATM needs for you to access your
bitcoins is your private key and which
output you are using but I'm so I'm
gonna use a beacon ATM so I'm not sure
what kind of interfaces well it has a
window where you show the QR code
I mean let's see um
[Music]
I'm just trying to see whether there's a
um I took a picture of the
object at the system
okay I mean this is a typical this seems
to be a where is there sorry I'm just
trying to so this seems to be
enforceable pull over that seems to be a
typical picture of a Bitcoin ATM okay so
there's a camera there and there's a
place to stick money in
and maybe there's a I guess what it does
is it probably shows you the transaction
ID here maybe as a QR code and then
maybe you take a picture of that it
doesn't give you the option to saying
you that are in Section 82 your email
well there doesn't seem to be a keyboard
here I know I'm on the screen right I'm
guessing it shows it on the screen um
okay
anyway I can try that um all right so
let me try to understand these other
workflows okay so what you've got
what was this so this is so over here
a pay - public key hash um
so we'll that's it that's a name of the
standard transaction yes but this is the
transaction we just went through or not
this example here is is yes a more
simplified version of the workflow so
workflow has all these steps okay but
what's so this starts off with a random
transaction ID well it's not random is
it one transaction ID where there's an
output we know we have access you right
okay fine and then this is now a new
transaction being done with that output
yes okay
so one question that I would have is you
know what does this graph look like of
you know transact them it's sort of a
ribbon thing of transactions flowing
into other transactions do we know what
that looks like can we make that graph
easily it's not hard to make the graph
that it takes it takes a while because
he needs to read different parts of a
blockchain right because the whole block
tramming have you seen is there a is
there a graph that have you seen this
graph I've seen a small graphs of
transactions and we have something like
that but it humbly award actions have
there been in the history of blockchain
do you know mmm no but we can obviously
although it will take a while I mean it
will be an interesting thing to record
since we since we know since we know it
up to a point we it will be a fun thing
to have in our blockchain block Jake
data wouldn't it um
yes we probably need a support database
for that so we don't query the blood
change it so yeah but maybe but for
every block we know how many
transactions that have been up to that
time right so right this new block we
just have to add so for example if
police say um so let's say for the first
20 blocks of the Bitcoin blockchain
okay so now what would I do i would say
blockchain transaction data
no judge yet you can just extract a
transaction list of launching book data
and okay so I just do that table let's
say was it did it start with block 0
block 1 what was the genesis block was
it not 0 okay I think this is so these
are just lists of all should work with
at least they're okay but so but these
all have one transaction in them right
yeah because that's what I would look at
a recent block
um and I were to look at transaction
list and I were to look at length of
that
I see so nowadays many of them have
quite long trend large numbers of
transactions usually yes
I'm now curious if I go we'll see what
block number are we at right now
um GD block shindaita
sure gathered the latest
locks half a million
okay so let's pick I mean I'm just
curious if we go to block um so if I do
this computation for blocks
you
I'm just this is just curiosity but I'm
if I say range let's say one to five
hundred thousand in steps of fifty
thousand or something
you
you
you
so this would give us some sense I see
so that's the growth of the number of
transactions per block in the Bitcoin
blockchain
interesting we should you know in this
course was supposed to be doing about
all the stuff things like this should be
part of it yeah Mason's
now I'm just gonna do the and you can
cool also at the time mind properties
that you also have the the actual date
and time right
okay so right blue the okay so now let's
say I see okay it gets a little bit more
squiggly okay it's interesting I wonder
what why this happens I mean I wonder
what the distribution of transaction
numbers in a block is that would be you
know is it a Poisson distribution what
is it okay all right so these are things
we can but I mean in terms of this graph
let's see the first
what would we have to do to find out
let's see we'd have to use the inputs
and the outputs to find out which
transactions relate to which other
transactions correct so if I were to
look at um
if i were to look at the transaction a
bunch of okay how about I see I can't
just say I have to have the transaction
IDs which I have to get from the block
right
okay I mean this will be interesting
things to do I mean again we need to be
getting ready our course that will
explain to people like the folks yeah
how all this stuff works and these will
be good them good things to have in
there okay so let's let's take a look at
some more of what you've got here and
then let's take a look at how our
computational facts system plugs into
all of this
but let's okay so we've got a theory on
transaction okay so we've got the
analogous transaction for aetherium is
that right
that's right um
a surprise
so
you
okay so now what is this that's oh I see
that's interesting okay so there's the
transaction ID okay that's an
interesting state that will be in um the
UM this is um
um
right so when we first do it like with
the blocked with the Bitcoin ATM what we
will see when we look at our transaction
is pending to mine
correct yeah if you just like if you get
the money from the faucet or the ATM you
need to wait oh well in the case of it
here which will be faster right guys
it's about ten seconds in theory or more
less oh really
it's like 10 minutes and Bitcoin and
Bitcoin yes okay and so what we would do
I mean it we could Paul essentially what
we're doing then is we we just have to
keep watching when will it you know will
mullet club you know when will it clear
okay okay alright so that's basically
just the analog of what we already saw
but for aetherium true
oh yes somehow my process is somewhat
different but it's in general the the
same thing making a transaction do we
have a workflow for aetherium here for
this type of an analogue of that
workflow for aetherium
yeah yes but these are drafts still
[Music]
okay so that's a faucet
okay for some totally bizarre reason the
hex is quoted in capital letters for
this case why I mean I don't think we
really care but I'm just curious what
the I mean these addresses what matters
is the hex is the bits right not the
actual characters of the hex it is
security measures for the aterial
addresses it is called a checksum it is
just verified that you didn't got any
laser of mistaking what's the checksum
part of it but some are capital letters
some of the lower case but yeah that's
cool okay but so so our encoder does
whatever is being done for that checksum
and produces it in a form do we say that
in the documentation for this I don't
think so why don't we say it just for
people like me who would otherwise be
confused um okay
all right so let's go here okay our
starting balance so that was different
from the Bitcoin case
because here we're asking for a balance
on a patent address right and whereas
here we did not have any such thing if I
remember correctly
here you asked for transaction so in
this case there's a transaction hash
here which are not entering here
I'm confused explain what's the analogy
between this case the Bitcoin case that
is showing here and the etherium case
that you're showing here
it is somewhat different because in the
case of Bitcoin the blockchain already
only stores the transactions and it is
up to you to take all to compute your
balance in the case of a theorem the
actual blockchain saves the balance so
in the case of children you just can
call the blockchain you got your balance
it is more straightforward
okay and so we couldn't use if I use
blockchain address data over here if I'm
um uh if I say for my efforts up here my
little ATM efforts if I said
for that right if I said here um
blockchain address data of that comma
what would I get if I did this what
would it give me what would what would
it tell me if I do this so try where I
shall working on making this war but for
this we also build in a support a de
base because as here I said that blood
she doesn't have that information so
we're constructing a database to return
to compete all these and return that
information so the blog train address
data can contain for a given address it
contains I see
I see
cool alright did we go over this I guess
we have alright okay fair enough
by the way you also had given me the
information about how to buy a crypto
kitty raw how would I do that I mean so
just walk me through the process if I
want to put by a crypto Kitty for I mean
if I if I were to look um
if I were to say blockchain token data
and now I'm going to say blockchain base
or do I even need to say a theorem what
happens if I just do let's see what
happens if I just want the top ten
tokens for example
you
just make sense so what am i yeah by
default it goes to a serial okay how do
i why is that failing that do I say like
10 or something here no what do I do to
get the top 10 the way you would do is
you would put all and they you would do
something like part or take okay so that
that is gonna give me what is that gonna
give me that's gonna give me if I say Oh
dataset that's gonna give me is that
really gonna give me all of the tokens
yeah but just only they are general
information okay so there are thousand
and twenty types of tokens on a theorem
right now is that correct well there are
two types of tokens and there are twenty
bit but what about so is this only
giving me LC 20 tokens no no it is only
also giving you seven to anyone there is
another stander so if I were to show
this just for example for the hell of it
if I just wanted to do something here
where I say let's look at the total
supply so then let's say here that's
just is this in any kind of order or is
this not ordered okay so let's just say
I want the name and I want some so let's
say I want line 19 and I want the name
and I want the total supply and
wrong oh whoops I need to say all okay
so now what I might want to do is let me
try to make a word cloud well let me
sort by what happens if I would do this
so it's gonna work okay
um now I just reverse this it's kind of
cruddy but I should have used reverse
sort by okay kin whatever they are are
the most have the largest total supply
so if I now say take that comma well
let's say take that comma 100 then I
could say for example what happens if I
say just word cloud of this is that
going to work
probably not with my guess I'd be very
surprised if that work because I don't
see how it can know what to do well
thinks it's doing something I can't
believe it thinks it's doing the right
thing let's take a look at how word
cloud normally works no it's going off
into lala land here it's probably doing
something absolutely crazy that's some
let's just look at how word cloud works
we need the wait arrow the symbol
so here we need to say % 24
well let's say normal percent 24 and
let's just be very simple-minded about
this hash to arrow hash 1 Amazon triple
@ sign that ok and then let's say word
cloud of that
you
come on why is it so hard oh I see free
coins seems to dominate but that's only
because it has a large supply can we
tell how many transactions have happened
with each of these tokens yes there is
when you are when you do blockchain
token data it gives you that information
or token how holders wait a minute
transfers count oh wow okay so I should
have done this by okay so actually let
me do this by
right
transfers count um and then let me say
reverse sort by
why didn't that work what did it do
wrong
reverse thought by that by transfers
count what did I do wrong
I am very confused
did I well let's just say sort by I mean
maybe there's some weird bug here but I
don't think so
sort that by truck what is going on
okay I am officially confused here um I
mean it's conceivable that reverse sort
by doesn't understand datasets that
would be absolutely shocking
so weird Oh unless reverse sort by does
anybody understand that can somebody
report that as a bug Carla could you yes
they can report that have somebody look
at it I don't know what went on there
okay so now let's do this
this is going to be more interesting so
that's probably some kind of Zipf
distribution of them so if I were to
look there Atem percent
oh I know what I did wrong I know what I
did wrong
maybe transfers count their loops
a magnificent distribution I wonder if I
were to take line 32 there and I were to
say log of that
let's just take the log there
well I'm gonna guess that's four just
find out I'm just curious if that's
exponential oops
um
what did it do there well certainly if I
say log of normal of that it should work
what does that mean that's some kind of
what is that that's really weird I mean
I would expect okay well anyway that
that's I would expect as if distribution
which means it would be on a log log
plot we would see
um
let's just see what that looks like
well okay fair enough
so it's it's kind of zipfian until until
we really lose it here at the at the
rare tokens um but I would guess here if
we were to say
let's see take I'm 32 comer a hundred
this should give us a word cloud of the
most popular tokens here oh okay that's
interesting crypto kitties
hmm okay that's kind of cool and we can
presumably do that can we do that back
in time like could we see the evolution
of this over time
yes we can but you will have to like
make mini calls mini blockchain token
data filtering by time and it would be
very computationally expensive yeah I
understand but I mean we can get some
snapshots at different times like last
year such and such
you
um okay okay
interesting all right so let's go back
here we were looking at the etherium
case all right
and this is you're saying the there's a
okay why do I need to know stuff about
gas prices because any transaction
involves gas as well correct
yes but the thing is you wanted to you
want a transaction to be mine so you
have to offer a good amount of of gas so
that's what we compute the highest gas
price of the last block and so you can
use that I see so it's like it's like
you know there's a certain amount of
giving like what happens if you do not I
mean your transaction might sit on mind
for a long time what's come on see the
unlined transactions and how many are
there I mean that they're tons where
people have just not offered enough of
the bounty and they're sitting there on
mind do we know ah yes there there is a
well there are no record in the
blockchain but there is no certain way
to know all of the a mine transaction
because every no hath a pool of pending
transaction so it could be fed to a
particular node and never makes it onto
the global blockchain right but how many
I mean like like you know nodes that
we're putting up how many random pending
transactions do they wind up having I
know Luke that's yet but we could do
that we could see in our low down and
count how many online transaction
dairies um okay well let's try look
ahead at some of these smart contracts
using well from expression as a payload
okay so what's the idea goal to deploy
automatically executable from contract
given by an expression to the etherium
test nut and verify the execution of
that okay so what is the basic flow
going to be here
we're puttin a in this case we're
putting a war from expression inside a
solidity contract and then it gets it
gets harvested executed and the contract
gets updated okay so that that's our
harvester that's coming in doing the
harvesting is that correct right okay
and our harvester is up and running
yes is it looking at just at the test
net or is it looking at the production
net as well or the production as well
yes okay so so okay that's very
interesting okay I didn't know that okay
so fine so let's put okay Wow cool all
right so
and where is if if there's a bounty
being paid to us for for mining that
transaction or for executing that
expression where does that show up
I mean in other words okay so here we've
got there's a gas price here we've got
this expression so when we okay we make
that
transaction we submit the transaction
then what's this here that's the
submitted transaction and how do we see
wait a minute where do we see this part
this part of the transaction
that held expression in the next part of
the whole flow when you do not change
contract value I see okay
it takes a few minutes to be harvested
hold on hold on so so how does it know
up here
so our harvester is looking for a
particular address is that correct or
what how does the harvester work
the harvester looks for a particular
topic if you scroll down a little bit
there is a property event in the
blockchain transaction data output and
that topic is what the harvester is
looking for what is this oh I don't
remember seeing this is that's a feature
of the ethereum blockchain yeah it is a
way to for the blockchain to communicate
with the external world okay so explain
that to me so this has what what is that
typically used for it is used for the
depth for the decentralized application
just for like it is used for crypto
queries when you send transaction to the
to the store of crypto kiddies the smart
contract triggers an an event and some
harvester the date that they've got in
their own servers reads that in the
blockchain and they send a transaction
that yeah okay this cryptic area now
belongs to you
but I thought that the whole point of
crypto code is is that the ledger of
what belongs to what is on the
blockchain that sounds like they're
maintaining a separate database yeah
they are separating on their are
maintaining a separate database under a
and they explain that in their website
in order to make like a it would be very
costly very expensive if they didn't do
that well but I understand but that's
still a ledger about who owns what which
is in principle disentangle from the
blockchain is that correct
yes that is correct I did not realize
that they had a shadow database
that was just you know a centralized
database in their server how shocking
because the points is because you're
saying that to disentangle who owns what
by tracing through that graph and the
blockchain is it's complicated yes yeah
well they explained it in their website
it is not like it is no secret that keep
the kiddies on their own servers yeah I
understand but so that means that they
know for example I mean when people as
an owner of a crypto kitty you you might
own it through multiple addresses
correct so that so you can't tell which
which crypto cat is a co-owned which
which cups are credits are owned by the
same person you can't easily tell that
if the person uses different addresses
to buy different crypto code is that
right I am Not sure I've seen that one
cryptic it is it can be on just by one
address okay okay fair enough no I
understand one crypto kitty you can't
have the same critically owned by two
addresses but you can have the same
address own to crypto kitties
right yes okay all right so let's go
back here
so what you're saying is now why is it
the case why does it take three to five
minutes to hunt for the for this thing
so it's women the topic
is I mean this is kind of shades of the
matrix as in the movie The Matrix this
is where we're watching for some topic
to show up that our harvester will
recognize to know that it should look at
that transaction is that right right
okay so then so what is out so we have a
particular like we have an IP address we
have a particular topic ID the
corresponds to our harvester yes right
okay how do we pick that topic ID the
topic ID is just the hash of some string
in this case is a physics string we hash
it with that it is just a fixed topic it
it is just my house will be random but
that topic must be known by the
harvester but we might as well have a
cute string there because this hash is
not secret right we can have a cute
string I mean at the very least we can
say you know the wolfram harvester or
something and have that be so everybody
can reproduce I mean what is that hash
by the way what kind of a hash is it it
is an association that says like
something like Voltron harvester version
one and we compress that Association and
we got ourself I string and we hash that
string okay okay okay all right
what do other people I mean we invented
this name harvester ages ago what do
other people call that functionality of
of watching the blockchain for something
since obviously that must be being done
by for example the crypto kitties as you
just explained by the coast kitty
central server yeah I wouldn't know how
they called that okay all right well
okay okay fine so our so why does it
take our harvester three to five minutes
to notice
this if the blocks are getting mined
every 10 seconds
right so there are these blocks that are
called
orphaned blocks that it happens when a
at some point two blocks are my other
two note mine the same block height but
with different transaction yeah so only
one of the blocks get into the block
chain and the other one gets like drop
and that those are called orphan blocks
so in order to for us to be really sure
that the blocks is going to last in the
block chain we have to wait for like six
blocks and there is around and two to
three minutes for waiting for
information general right the in
principle you know it's it's like
reverse of irreversibility and
thermodynamics type thing I mean in
principle you could have to wait
arbitrarily long to know that the
blockchain is not going to reverse
itself
right because it's just you know it's
piling stuff on but eventually it can
you know you're saying the probability
of the blockchain not of a block that
has been added to the main blockchain of
that blockchain being reversed out
through it failing to reach consensus
becomes perhaps exponentially lower I
don't know that's again data that one
could get I mean that would be
interesting data to get because one do
we have the information to get that data
we probably don't because we only know
the consensus blockchain right all right
yeah we all have that okay okay so
basically you're saying we wait for
consensus to be reached before we
harvest the thing we wait for consensus
and then the harvester in order to
execute the contract it deploys another
transaction or we have to wait for that
next transaction a generated by the
harvester get mine so okay but the
harvesters transaction how does the
harvester get paid
to get paid because a bounty has been
offered on the original transaction that
was submitted or what I know we're
currently we are not charging for you
have to put any theorem address in the
transaction that points to to us okay so
so we need to figure out how to do that
I mean if the so presumably we don't
want people to know okay do we will
probably oh no it will probably the same
mechanism as when we asked us for the
computational facts that we provide yes
I would think so we need to develop the
same yet the same mechanism for both
things yes right but but Oh in
particular we don't want people to be
able to tell on the blockchain which
contracts happen to be using
computational facts from us presumably
or maybe we do I don't know maybe it's
good marketing to be able to go look at
the topics and see their resilience of
wolf and harvester topics there
Dula mark saying or is it considered
problematic that somebody can tell I
mean which contracts happen to make use
of computational facts from us
I'm not sure maybe maybe John has an
opinion about that not really although
it does highlight that we should review
view other smart contracts and are using
facts out there
yeah well okay fine so we should
determine the answer to that but but
basically then this whole transaction
will get a bit more complicated because
it will also be sending to an address
some amount of um of cryptocurrency how
do we determine what is the price list
for computational facts
in other words if if somebody asks to
you know if for their computational fact
they ask for to discover the next you
know Mersenne Prime or something right
something that's gonna burn tons of CPU
time what do they what how is this
supposed to work is it's supposed to
work that basically you say I will you
you know that you test the computational
fact query you say that takes X number
of cloud credits that number of cloud
credits translates into this price on
the blockchain therefore I will offer
you this bounty on the blockchain to do
this computation is that is that what we
expect to have happen
guys I'm Kinky's jr. say again please
okay okay so look what I'm imagining is
that there is a version of this
transaction that requests that says I'm
providing this Wolfram language
expression that I want to evaluate it
that is the thing that is going to
determine my fact okay okay I'm gonna
say presumably I'm gonna test this so
I'm gonna know this type of fact takes
three cloud credits actually we're now
unifying that system so like three
Wolf's and credits to compute okay I
then look up a price list that says
three whorfin credits equals
such-and-such a number of way on
etherium okay I then say great I will
put that price in way as the thing that
I am paying to get the harvester to do
its cycle and return the results of the
of evaluating that expression to the
blockchain makes sense yes okay but
we're gonna have to have such a you know
there's got to be a price list and it's
got to be presumably there's the you
know the market price on the day for
that number of computation credits and
in principle that market price could
float if for example other people offer
the computation services for instance
but in other words somehow it's got to
know when you set this up so one thing
that I don't quite understand is there's
sort of a futures question because what
has to happen is you say I'm gonna set
up this contract one day it's going to
trigger and it's going to want to know
the temperature in timbuktu that day I'm
making sense but that day might be six
months from now or a year from now okay
I know it's gonna cost three Wolfram
credits to do that computation okay but
the question of how much you know the
price
Etha has gone up or down you know what
is the conversion rate between what what
do you have to put into your contract on
day zero to make sure that you have
enough I mean I guess it's basically gas
in there too except I'm not sure we're
using are we using gas or are we using
ether to to do these things isn't yes
what yeah I think we because gas is only
used for internal solidity execution
okay so we're using ether so now the
question is what happens if when you set
up this transaction the price of ether
was X when the transaction comes to be
executed many months later the price of
ether is something different right right
so for us you know or whoever is
providing computation services they
basically it's like a you know it's like
futures or something you're saying I
will offer to do this transaction six
months from now
I will offer to do a one wolfram credit
transaction for such and such an amount
of ether am I making sense
I might confused somehow I mean it's
like saying and then in principle
somebody's making a bit of a background
noise here in principle one could
imagine being able to resell that condo
I mean essentially that's a contract to
perform that computation at some point
in the future my making sense yes so and
in principle one can have a secondary
market or even a primary market of
saying okay you know it's not worth my
while okay so first of all some of those
computations some of those transactions
may never happen that is the other set
of circumstances that cause that smart
contract to trigger may never actually
ask the computation to be done so
be that somebody paid you oh I see you
don't get paid in this model which is
not obviously the correct model you
don't get paid until you actually do the
transaction it's not obvious that that's
the right model it doesn't seem like
right I mean but but so but risk in that
and having to execute that contract in
six months yes but but how would this
work if you had to get paid up front
because if you get paid up front how do
you know that then it requires a
different protocol and maybe some token
mechanism or something for you to be
able to say I'm getting it paid upfront
and then this contract will be set in a
state this thing will be set in a state
where when it is requested it will be
computed
but makes sense yeah I mean it makes
much more sense I agree with you
because otherwise you're in this futures
business I makes much more sense to say
pay now it's gonna cost this number of
credits of wolfram credits pay now and
then okay so guys I think you need to
figure out what the what the protocol is
did you get what I'm saying
Johan yes yes yeah yeah but I think
there might be many more cases and this
ol will have to we all have to figure
out a bit for every one of them so I
think that if you put a contract them
has to be executed in six months then
you probably use the price at that
station and that's it
or you could prepay for I don't know
there there should be many cases to
think about yes I see what you mean
right
okay so actually another thing which I'd
like to bring up here
the what if we were storing data for
somebody what if in our cloud we end up
let's see how does this work I mean this
I maybe I'm just confusing myself but
but let's imagine that I want to put
some data somewhere
and then
I see and that then in six months
somebody else yeah yeah you well okay
there's right so that there's a bunch of
cases that that that's that's I think a
different thing but as soon as we can do
these as soon as we can do an arbitrary
evaluation that evaluation could put
data into our cloud in other words we
could do an evaluation a computation
that where one contract saves data into
the cloud and another contract knows the
same address and can retrieve that data
later
am i making sense
yep I mean in other words there's
persistence there's nothing if if we are
assuming that every transaction every
computation sent to the harvester is
executed in the same cloud right then it
will be the case
I mean the I mean the alternative is to
is to require that the thing be
stateless so that for example it could
be the case that there's a whole swarm
of clouds so to speak um
a whole storm of clouds or something
that um are
um so you don't necessarily know when
you ask for this transaction for this
computation to be done you won't because
it's stateless you don't know in advance
which which you know which machine is
going to compute it and then obviously
the limiting case is the absurd case of
aetherium where all the nodes compute it
but that's I think uh turley unnecessary
um you know if you have a large pool of
nodes and you know a randomly chosen one
computes it or in the most extreme case
three randomly chosen ones computer
you're pretty safe um but so that I mean
that's a case we don't really understand
is whether whether the expression that
we gave is a stateless thing that come
that will give the same answer whenever
it's computed or whether it can store
State okay but anyway so we obviously
need that protocol oh look at this smart
contracts working with external storage
what do you know that's the next item
here um what is this why do we need
hold diagram why do we need this why do
we need so in the first case we are
putting the expression that we once
evaluated roar onto the blockchain right
right okay the second case what if we
want a thousand line program executed
then the idea is to store the thousand
line program in in ipfs to retrieve it
execute it and give the result is that
correct yes okay now as a practical
matter which do we expect to be the more
common I mean okay so so in the I mean
if you had built
I see the whole point is that you want
it to be a raw stateless war from cloud
in general that executes things so you
can't for example have stored an API in
the cloud that just does your thousand
line program or a million line program
or whatever it is that right he wants it
to be stateless so that any any Wolfram
cloud anywhere could execute it
okay let's see we have all kinds of
comments on the live stream here all
right Michael says I think I get it
could be code that depends on the exact
time it is run
let me understand this okay that's and
that's an important point
um the code depends on the when it's run
like it's asking for the current date so
one question is what is the user
metadata of code that is being run from
the harvester to go what I'm saying like
like for example if you're running
something in the cloud the cloud knows
the IP address if you run an API in the
cloud that API gets to know the IP
address of the caller go what I'm saying
and certain other user metadata
so a question would be in I mean so so
this is if we look at um what is the
name of that variable gosh I should
remember um dollar evaluation
environment okay so the harvester
represents so we have certain evaluation
environments like for example it is a
evaluated in a I mean here are see here
are some cases right a sub kernel it's a
web evaluation cloud evaluation
initiated by an HTTP request so there
will presumably be another evaluation
environment for the harvester is that
true
I think so yeah I haven't checked this
yet I think that's good I think it's
what we'll want to do because you know
this will get see the whole point is
when you do that right so if you say use
a method data if you look at the user
meta data cloud execution metadata okay
so this shows you for example if you are
being executed as an HTTP request you
get this HTTP request data sent to you
as part of the you can retrieve this you
know when you execute that particular
computation here what I'm saying so
there's a question of how much metadata
do we pass to the harvester when we tell
it to do the computation what do we know
we know a bunch of stuff because we know
which block the harvester pick this
thing up from etc etcetera etcetera we
know a ton of sweet we basically know
the transaction that contained this
request and we will want to send that
just like we know the transaction the
HTTP transaction that contained the
request that we're now executing we have
the same kind of thing for the
blockchain makes sense yep so I mean my
guess is it's going to be basically the
same as the contents of blockchain
transaction data just like this is the
same as the contents of an HTTP request
packet right if I say if I look at the
this HTTP request data okay let's try to
understand this this HTTP request right
what we get from HTTP request data is
the cloud side view of the incoming HTTP
request I believe plus some other stuff
some other metadata like the IP address
that's originating at anyway we need to
understand the analogue here um
okay but the question islets see so
Michael is saying so I guess the
harvester code will be official and you
would instruct it to write any important
results you want to appropriate
addresses on the blockchain
well now what are we actually doing so
the harvester result right now you are
you are saying where to send it is that
correct in the original setup you told
it where to send the results from the
evaluation is that true
yes okay um
carl is asking about Wolfen credits and
I'm not at the frontlines of that that's
a the main issue is that we have had
separate credits for using cloud CPU
time and using external services like
sending text messages or calling
external api's and there is a whole
scheme for merging these and I don't
can't claim to understand it the
difficulty is that some of them are
things that are under our control how
much they cost and other other things
are not under our control how much they
cost but I think by having essentially
exchange rates we can control that uhm I
think that's coming in the next few
months okay
then is asking as saying he's interested
in the use of blockchain for health
records and health statistics yeah yeah
so we've been involved in in a bunch of
folks talking about that I think that
you're the
the best mate maybe can somebody say
John or somebody else or somebody else
say what the current thinking is about
the protocol for how you would do
medical records stuff on the blockchain
I mean in a perfect world you might use
you know fully homomorphic encryption to
be able to write medical records to the
blockchain and be able to then compute
with them while they remain encrypted so
to speak but absent that what is the
what's the protocol what's the workflow
for doing medical records stuff I mean
now that I kind of think about it what's
likely to happen is that someone's going
to create a more specialized DLT just
for dealing with medical records that
that's likely more more likely to happen
than someone sort of looking at existing
DLTS that are out there and trying to
come up with some solutions I mean okay
but I mean in principle you could use
you know you could use our blockchain to
just throw data I mean you know our
blockchain lets you put data on there
but that's not really the use case the
use case is that you want to be able to
you know globally store I mean I think
it's more of an i you know an IP FS like
play actually you want to be able to
globally store things in essentially a
global database and have
I mean the difficulty is who gets to
access it and who gets to access which
pieces of it I think I mean I don't even
know how it works and you know if you
you know if you have let's say you you
have your electronic health record and
it's held by some particular you know
some you you go to some you know medical
practice that's part of some Hospital
chain and then you want to go to some
other specialist in that hospital chain
what do they actually get access to do
you know
in other words do they get either full
access to your medical record or they
get nothing or do they get or is there
some mechanism for giving them partial
access I don't know that's a good
question do you know that each each
organisation has their own you know
structured system of medical records
well I know but I'm asking you know if
you just buy your system from epic or
something then is it the case that
specialists what's that I think each one
has their own system like even of agric
I say something where with different
schemas and things or something yes
but I mean the question that I'm asking
is you know specialists one gets you
know put certain data into your medical
record does specialists - if they see
anything do they automatically see what
specialist one put into your medical
record um I mean that's something we can
obviously determine I don't know the
answer to that but I mean that's
presumably it would be you know that's
the type of thing which would the right
encryption mechanisms and so on one
could segment things in a nice way and
one could have something with multiple
signatures and things that are required
for certain kinds of things but I you
know presumably I mean we've interacted
with enough of these people trying to do
this somebody must have SPECT this out I
would hope right I think that's where
your custom ledger that actually stores
the medical data on oh sure sure you
don't want a store you're not gonna
store medical data on you know certainly
not gonna store it in some way in the
etherion blockchain that's completely
senseless I mean the only the only use
case there is the case where you put
your medical records there and you say a
pharma company can look at my records by
paying me X number of X amount of money
right that's that's that case right
having some pointer to the actual
records but and that's what I'm saying
like I think the people were actually
willing to solve the problem in a
reasonable way are just going to rethink
and create a custom medical data ledger
no doubt no doubt and it might cross
connect with the public cryptocurrencies
for you know in order for that to be
some possibility of people buying stuff
through cryptocurrencies if they want to
do that but sorry no no no well anyway
the the let's see Michael on our live
stream says I wrote like a thousand
lines of solidity code last year for an
order booking and bidding system
somebody wanted users had to transfer
the max amount of ether they were
willing to pay with their bid then the
behavior of the open source contract
would automatically refund them if their
bid wasn't selected
okay interesting by the way for that
case what do we imagine
going to provide in the future that
would allow that contract I mean are we
expecting that we are going to compile
to solidity for certain kinds of from
certain kinds of code so we're going to
compile to native
you know let's say a theorem smart
contracts is there some possibility of
that or are we not imagining that's
going to happen right now you know
that's that's one of the projections we
have but is it going to work through
LLVM and through the compiler or is it
going to work through another mechanism
probably the classical compiler okay but
then but there are specialized
operations that exist in solidity that
presumably are not that right now I
don't think a part of our language and
so wouldn't be picked up by the compiler
in other words what if when we write the
the solidity the etherion virtual
machine right how far have we gotten
writing the etherion virtual machine how
we carry a good progress sir and we are
actually talking about the building the
sylheti compiler
well meant that but that solidity
compiler which way round of a compiler
are you talking about
we're still discussing about that by
about the virtual machine we have
basically all up codes okay implemented
okay so so then
shove those opcodes do not have an
analog in Wolfram language
I mean clearly opcodes that say add this
to that they have analogs
right but there are opcode that don't
I think the one said require access to
the blockchain to DT or blockchain and
that means that each theorem in context
there so that's something we we still
can actually could you show could you
show the progress of the PBM thing is
that sure just let me get the notebook
wincing okay do you want to send it to
me or do you want to show it on your
machine
I can sanity okay why don't you do that
boy we didn't even get through all of
these workflows this is terrible this is
a complicated subject when are we gonna
have our course about this guys how is
that coming along
[Music]
well I think we're you know we're
working on the non-public stop too so
right well it just seems like we've got
a lot of good material here too
yeah um by the way I don't understand
why other than because your your
incoming or outgoing data is large why
would you use external storage for a
computational fact
what's the point of having this an
external storage why don't you just have
it as part of the payload on the
blockchain itself
unless it's big and you have to have a
pointer I mean it's the difference
between cloud evaluate and executing an
API in the cloud
or is there a different reason is there
a reason like you might want the code to
be secret
John saying that somebody might in a
third party case somebody might want to
write code that they say this code is
gonna be an amazing thing it's gonna
predict the stock market and you just
have to call it but you can't see my
code well that's that's one of the
reasons other than it would be if the
code would be too large it would be more
expensive to destroy in a smart contract
and solidity as well why is it expert
how does this price vary with the size I
thought I just had some size limit and
you just put the stuff in up to that
size limit you're not paying to my
knowledge although you perhaps should be
you're not paying to have everybody
replicate you know your stuff throughout
the etherion blockchain you're only
paying the cost of replicate this
transaction right you're not saying it
isn't it isn't counting the number of
bytes and saying we'll charge you more
because more bytes
that correct no it does count the number
of bytes
really yeah so you pay more depending on
the size of the smart contract through
the gas price through gas price okay all
right well let's take a quick look here
small contracts using solidity I just
sent you the IBM interpreter okay and
what um
okay let's take a look here my gosh
so is there something runnable here
there are some examples at the end yes
so I have to execute this the self
initialization cells in it or do I just
execute all this stuff at the top what
do I do
oh it's it's got initial yes okay I
don't know what that wrapper is okay
testing examples okay so let's go ahead
and decide this oops just render scrub
and render wrapper Oh No so the dice
yeah it's not an actual initialization
right okay let's try it again okay so
this is add two and three okay what on
earth am i seeing there so those the
successive states of the EVM so that's
that's in a sense the tape of EVM is
blank and these are the registers of EVM
that right
I think it would be good didn't we have
a spec for this I think it would really
really be good to give the state of the
EVM as an association that lists the
state of each register etc etc etc I
think that was the original spec that
I'd made at least I pull that out again
let's see did you have that still the UM
do you have that information me and well
but you must have had it at one point
because we have an act oh no no Joker
you're talking about I think the bitcoin
is interpreter fine but I had a spec for
how to represent virtual machines right
remember that I think so how'd she look
for that okay
so let me see um
under what this is
I've got several of these let's take a
look
it's not it um hold on
the guy should be able to find it let's
try this
okay that's an old thing here
that was an old version I don't when
that's from a
that's
that's an old thing um let's take a look
here
that's a different thing again
well it's from a year ago it's
interesting
you
you
okay um okay
well I I'm I'm certain that I gave you
this so
ah let me just see um one more place it
might be
you
you
yeah well I had some notes here um but
this was very minor there were many more
notes for how this should work okay so I
mean the basic idea is what it should
eventually have is a virtual machine
function right which can list a bunch of
op codes operate on a state and return a
new state it makes sense right okay
so it so for instance so that's not what
this is doing
that's taking a script oh I see no that
is more or less what it's doing
but this is I mean the analog of this
for example for a um
okay this is the analog for register
machines
it has the exact same type of thing it
has an executor ninh it has this evolved
list which is giving the successive
states of the machine which is
essentially what you're doing here right
that makes sense
anyway I strongly believe that you
should represent the state of the
machine by an association I don't even
know what these things are these may be
operands op op bum oh hell are they
called
operands for that opcode but I don't
know I don't understand any of this I'm
sorry I don't understand what
what is the hundred there
what does that represent I reckon please
sure and I mean we it still have to work
in the design so we have all these
back-end ok well this looks nice though
what's that that's some symbolic
representation of a hex value that's
weird so that's again I mean these are
the kinds of things we need to
understand is what new constructs do we
need to have to support what is being
done with the PBM
I thought um we had a project at the
summer camp I think to implement knuth
mix virtual machine did that did that
ever happen or was that simply on my
list nobody picked it up remember I can
check okay
I remember the new machine right I mean
that's just an example I mean eventually
we could have 8086
machine code here as well who wants it -
um
okay I mean another thing that'd be fun
to do is random programs here see what
the random EVM program actually does
I've never really done that I I did that
experiment like 25 years ago with them
some risk um I'm kind of risk
instruction set and it was very
uninteresting it I mean it just
most most sequences of instructions the
thing crashed Michael on a live stream
is saying that the hundred might be a
gas amount and I agree with that claim
um yeah that's using that might be using
progressively more gas yeah
also I found a post about the Mme mmm ix
organ and I share that on on the soon
chat yeah go ahead
okay
I see
that's a bit of a mess okay
I see so then it took code from Don
Knuth box and then did he successfully
parse it
yes
okay oh that's cool well why doesn't
show it actually running
hmm well okay well maybe he didn't get
all of the
all of the opcodes implemented anyway
but but look we need a standardized way
to represent virtual machines and I
would suggest I mean we can we can do
another discussion at some point to go
through that but I think just like those
register machines that you know the
theoretical register machines that I
have ok so this is these are extremely
simple machines right so this is a
machine where it has a program counter
position within the program and it has
two registers with content so that's the
position of the program counter those
are the values of the registers make
sense yeah I think so
one would assume that the way this works
is that there's a thing that says
program counter arrow and then value and
then you know register values maybe
arrow and then whatever's on the
registers right and that's the state and
that then this program that program
consists of simply saying increment this
color coding gray coding says that's
increment register - increment register
one decrement register one and this
machine has a decrement skip on 0 as I
recall
makes sense so what it's doing is if
that reaches zero right so you can see
what it's doing right every time
the thing reaches instruction three that
thing execute the
shoots the I see so on the decrement
skip on zero
the skip has to say where its
destination is in this model right so
it's saying go back set the program
counter back to position one make sense
so what what you would see here is as
that code I was showing will just
generate a series of you know program
counter is one program counter is to
program hundreds three register values
are blah blah blah right
and so for example well there's an
example of a more complicated machine
you know program right operating within
that same machine
and then what you would do is you you
you specify the program you specify the
initial state which in this case here is
a program counter one and register value
zero and zero okay then you simply are
doing you're saying how many steps do
you want to run the virtual machine for
and you run it and it will do what it
does right
does this making sense to people and and
you know in order to you know you should
be able to make this graphic by
basically just picking out the values in
um in there and I don't know whether in
the case of the EVM whether there's a
notion of program counter is there there
must be there must be cuz it that must
have you must be able to can it can do
loops right it's got to be able to do
loops
yes
ah you should be able to do the lips yes
because is okay so these are register
values I assume right so I don't know
what this means here but it's got to be
able to well jump dest what does that
mean I wonder
there's a link at the top of notebook I
believe to the general paper okay but
but so to represent
okay you've just got to be able to
represent the state of the machine and I
believe the state of the machine is the
memory plus the program counter
that makes sense yeah I think so
I think there's an appendix with the
opcodes
have to go a second here so um
I think we have to continue this meeting
um because I think there's more to
understand we clearly unearthed a few
issues which we were not aware of and
hopefully we'll have a good crisp set of
things to say in about two weeks itself
by um
right it will be nice to okay so do you
want to have a separate meeting to talk
about virtual machines and how they
should be set up I think we kind of are
going to need that and I would recommend
that we plan on using
machines from the ankus book as kind of
the 0th case
that makes sense okay
and I don't know okay let me explain one
more thing so so typically these virtual
machines they have registers and they
also have main memory more analogous to
the tape of a Turing machine for example
okay rather than the registers of a
register machine and I don't know how we
should deal with that in the
representation of the virtual machine
um
so Michael is saying his experience in
coding in solidity last year was that
was easier than assembly language but
more tedious than see no floating-point
numbers had to convert everything into
integer operations on rationals tracking
separate numerators and denominators
that sounds like a joy I had to write
separate lists to pedal functions for
every data type
yeah um yeah interesting um
well I mean then the question okay so
you understand there's an issue how to
represent main memory can you I mean I
believe those are the things that
computers have basically is you know
right we may need to if we're gonna do a
discussion about virtual machines we may
need to get somebody in there who knows
about machine code level programming um
in detail so we should figure that out
there's probably somebody in warrens
group who knows that possibly somebody
oh maybe we just need some one of the
older people in the company like me
who's actually programmed in assembly
language at some point um but but that's
what we're gonna need to have from um to
have a meaningful discussion about that
but okay so virtual machine discussions
one discussion okay I think we need to
finish going through these some I I
don't understand this here yet
[Music]
what is this
so this is solidity code what's the
point of this
you
you
so Carl on livestream is asking can we
use the GNU Compiler to convert Wolff
language code to solidity code that is a
good question that depends on whether
there is an LLVM to solidity converter
but no doubt our intermediate code for
the compiler which is symbolic
intermediate code would be a good
intermediate code for final conversion
so solidity but that's a whole separate
thing to create the code generator that
goes from the intermediate
representation to to solidity code and
it would be easier if somebody else has
already written an LLVM authority
converter um
why are we what what what are we looking
at here
okay great so this is a library that
does trivial I mean I don't understand
it and by the way when you use solidity
presumably every part of the code you're
using has to be on included in the
blockchain and that presumably since
you're telling me it costs gas to store
stuff that means your contract has to
contain all of the code is that true
that is true
okay so Carl said he's found one that
goes the other direction from I see from
evm - this is from EVM
what does this do you know I find it
so infuriating that these things is a
state okay as library for just-in-time
compilation okay right so it creates
LLVM code from
from IBM makes sense it allows you to
run a VM in lrvm virtual machine
okay so what's this this is what on
earth are we doing here this is using
that solidity code what are we doing
here
we're trying to deploy a solidity
contract okay
and what's that contract supposed to do
it outputs a finicky number it is just a
simple example but it is written
insulating I feel
okay so this is our typed specification
translated a version of our type
specification for solidity right
okay
okay this is a different thing all right
well I think we have to continue um
great
well that was useful um at least for my
understanding of things um and terrific
okay well thank you all and thanks to
folks on the livestream and talk to you
later
okay bye